[Música]
a
escala en parís aída palau
bienvenidos a todos a este programa de
radio francia internacional y de france
24 seguramente ustedes hayan visto unas
imágenes inéditas de campos franceses
alumbrados con miles y miles de hogueras
fue en el mes de abril y es que las
temperaturas cayeron hasta menos cinco
grados y los viticultores de la borgoña
encontraron en el fuego a su mejor
aliado para no perder sus cosechas y
estas espectaculares imágenes nos sirven
hoy para hablarles del impacto del
cambio climático en la agricultura y lo
hacemos con un experto en el tema iñaki
garcía de cortázar bienvenido muchas
gracias y ya que usted es doctor
ingeniero agrónomo y trabaja en el
instituto nacional de agricultura
alimentación y medio ambiente de francia
el inra eh
nunca antes había habido heladas como
las que vimos en abril es un signo del
cambio climático las heladas son algo
que ocurre cada año prácticamente suelen
estar distribuidas espacialmente
diferente este año la particularidad es
que ha cubierto todo el territorio
nacional prácticamente
las heladas están disminuyendo con el
cambio climático tenemos cada vez menos
días fríos durante el año lo que es un
signo del cambio climático es que la
vegetación empieza su desarrollo cada
vez más temprano entonces lo que ha
ocurrido este año con la viticultura y
con los árboles frutales es que las
flores y las yemas de los brotes de la
viña habían ya ha empezado a crecer
cuando ha habido
una helada general que ha destruido la
mayoría de las producciones en francia
esta es la ciencia la tecnología lo que
se llama los ciclos de los de los seres
vivos no es y de qué forma está
cambiando el clima en francia y cómo
está influyendo justamente en esa
tecnología la tecnología es el ciclo de
los seres vivos que es recurrente cada
año la germinación es las floraciones
las migraciones también la aparición de
los diferentes insectos el cambio
climático lo que está afectando es que
esos ciclos que hasta hace unos 30 40
años estaban más o menos estabilizados
ahora cada vez son más rápidos o más
temprano en el año y en los árboles por
ejemplo lleva a que las hojas de los
árboles se caigan cada vez más tarde y
entonces eso está afectando la totalidad
de la producción del desarrollo de las
plantas y en las plantas agrícolas la
posición de cuando la madurez o las
cosechas se producen
estos cambios de qué manera han
modificado por ejemplo la uva es
diferente el vino que tomamos ahora que
vemos ahora del vino que se bebía hace
unos 30 a 40 años si está cambiando
bastante y además lo hemos podido
observar porque eso es una de las
particularidades de nuestro trabajo
miramos lo que va a pasar en el futuro
pero lo primero que hacemos es mirar lo
que ha pasado en el pasado y lo que
observamos es que en estos últimos 30 y
40 años la uva por ejemplo ha aumentado
la cantidad de azúcar que hay en el
interior ha bajado también su acidez lo
cual genera un producto que cuando los
enólogos tienen que trabajar con él
produce más alcohol o produce menos
acidez dentro del vino y entonces si los
vinos han cambiado cada vez hemos ganado
más o menos prácticamente un grado de
alcohol en cada botella en los últimos
40 años hemos ganado un grado cada 10
años o sea que prácticamente 4 grados de
alcohol y al mismo tiempo hemos bajado
de medio gramo por litro que es bastante
de acidez lo cual genera de vinos con
una tipicidad y con una complejidad
diferente de la que la conocíamos antes
a parte del vino
de la vida y otros cultivos afectados no
se verduras frutas cereales o las
verduras en general tenemos menos
información las frutas también las
frutas están siguiendo exactamente el
mismo proceso que la uva por ejemplo las
mandarinas en córcega que es una
producción muy importante en esta isla
lo que vemos es que tenemos el mismo
problema con la acidez porque la acidez
disminuye fuertemente se hace el calor y
también el color en los cítricos el
color está disociado del gusto que pasa
es que los consumidores les gusta tener
frutos que sean o amarillos o naranjas y
el calor hace que los frutos se queden
verdes entonces aunque el sabor es bueno
los consumidores son menos propensos a
comprar esos frutos negros ya que
podemos comprar una mandarina verde que
sea muy dulce que esté perfectamente de
nivel con de consumo pero bueno estamos
intentando buscar cómo mantener un
producto que tenga la calidad que
necesitamos y al mismo tiempo que el
consumidor
cuál es la peor amenaza para los
agricultores
de este cambio climático
que se pierdan las cosechas que la
calidad de la fruta cambie que el tipo
de fruta a cambio sea que comamos una
fruta verde cuando ya está madura los
problemas a los cuales se están
encontrando los agricultores hoy son de
diversos tipos el principal hoy que
vemos es todo lo que es el carácter
aleatorio de las situaciones extremas
porque hasta ahora teníamos una noción
del cambio climático como un aumento de
la temperatura un cambio un poco de la
pluviometría y eso permitía proyectarse
hacia un tipo de agricultura dentro de
unos años el principal problema que
vemos estos últimos años es que cada año
tenemos una serie de eventos de
situaciones extremas puede ser una
canícula puede ser una sequía puede ser
una helada y lo principal es que puede
haber en el mismo año dos o tres
situaciones de esas que antes había un
año una situación para los agricultores
eso genera una inestabilidad en la
producción y entonces la viabilidad
económica de sus producciones es la que
está en riesgo ahí es donde intentamos
trabajar para ayudarles para que tengan
sistemas y y estructuras de producción
que nos permite mantener su nivel
durante muchos años no sé si ustedes
desde el inra yacen en la de
producciones de este tipo pero en algún
día si seguimos así
se hará vino en el norte de europa
naranjas no sé en bruselas o cómo va si
trabajamos en esos temas trabajamos e
intentamos entender qué es lo que ha
pasado en el pasado intentamos saber
cómo puede evolucionar la agricultura en
el futuro para definir estrategias de
adaptación
efectivamente una de las estrategias es
todo lo que es
evolucionar los sistemas de producción
que tenemos hay que saber ya que por
ejemplo la viticultura que tiene cada
vez mejores condiciones para
desarrollarse en el norte pero una de
las pero ya tenemos territorios en los
cuales empezamos a ver viticultura que
no era típico bretaña la bretaña
francesa en el norte de francia en
suecia y empieza a ver las primeras
parcelas de viña así que esas cosas
existen ahora bien lo que no sabemos es
si va a ser económicamente viable como
para imaginar que vamos a tener viñedos
de una importancia suficiente como para
entrar en competición con los viñedos
actuales pero esas cosas las estudiamos
si en el norte en la climatología hará
que se pueda
y hacer vino en el sur que va a pasar en
el sur lo que intentamos y hay
oportunidades y hay riesgos en el suelo
que intentamos es limitar los riesgos y
entonces lo que estamos intentando ver
es qué tipo de producción y qué tipo de
técnica agronómica o de adaptación
podemos proponer a los productores para
mantener sus sistemas de producción o
hacerlos evolucionar hacia otros
sistemas por ejemplo teniendo en cuenta
a la agroecología por ejemplo justamente
hablemos de cómo se pueden adaptar a
corto y medio plazo los agricultores
para no perderla las cosechas a corto
plazo trabajamos en lo que nosotros
llamamos técnicas agronómicas es decir
que intentamos que lo que es un saber
hacer de los agricultores se puede
integrar directamente en el campo y
hacerles cambios a corto plazo que puede
ser el cambio de fechas de siembra el
cambio de plantaciones la introducción o
el test de nuevas variedades a medio
plazo ya empezamos a pensar qué tipo de
adaptación económicamente interesante
puede integrarse en los sistemas el
riego en algunas zonas en las cuales no
estaba desarrollado o todo lo que pueden
ser ya estructuración es del sistema un
poco más importante es que van a
necesitar más inversiones pero que
permiten estar cubiertos para más años y
es una alternativa alterna a leer
alterar aún más genéticamente según que
cultivos hoy en día no es una de las
estrategias que estamos explorando no
buscamos tanto la alteración genética de
los cultivos lo que estamos intentando
es explorar la biodiversidad que existe
de ella en los que ya existen los
cultivos hay que saber que por ejemplo
si hablamos de la vid hoy en día tenemos
siete mil variedades diferentes es que
existen en el mundo en francia- podemos
cultivar 300 pero solamente 20 de esas
variedades cubren 90% de la superficie
del territorio vitícola nacional lo que
intentamos es explorar esas otras 280
para ver qué interés podemos tener en
valorizar las dentro del campo y
proponer a los agricultores de poder
explorar nuevas proposiciones de
variedades hace falta también educar o
acompañar el consumidor para que acepte
esas modificaciones porque la gente hay
veces que no está acostumbrada a nuevos
gustos nuevos sabores nuevos nuevas
texturas entonces hay que hay que hacer
un trabajo en los dos niveles y antes
luego cavamos rápidamente pero en el
caso del vino por ejemplo se pueden
hacer modificaciones por ejemplo si el
la tasa de alcohol es muy alta se pueden
hacer modificaciones en el momento de la
vinificación no se pueden hacer
modificaciones por hoy en día son cosas
que se hacen más bien de forma puntual
son cosas que se estudian efectivamente
que estamos explorando para saber si
mañana pueden ser otro tipo de
alternativas pero intentamos trabajar
desde el momento en el cual estamos en
el campo hasta el momento de la
producción para tener la mayor gama de
posibilidades de adaptación y de de
y de entrar dentro de lo que se puede
producir que la gente va a aceptar y qué
opinan los agricultores con los que han
hablado desde el instituto
tenemos bueno trabajamos nosotros
trabajamos con los agricultores
trabajamos sobre todo con los servicios
técnicos con los institutos técnicos de
investigadores de diferentes sectores de
producción
los agricultores son muy conscientes de
la situación actual están muy
preocupados con lo que está pasando
están muy a la expectativa de saber qué
es lo que podemos proponer ellos mismos
están probando muchas cosas intentando
explorar alternativas a los cuales
nosotros intentamos también ayudarles
para saber si son cosas que pueden tener
una viabilidad al mismo tiempo lo que
intentamos es acompañarles en la en la
reflexión sobre varios años porque ellos
tienen una temporalidad que es necesaria
para ellos de 1 o 2 años respecto a lo
que va a ser la producción económica
nosotros intentamos también imaginar
cómo van a ser las cosas dentro de 10 20
40 años para que ellos puedan
proyectarse hacia el futuro y hay
urgencia para implementar
estas adaptaciones
ciertas adaptaciones hay urgencia porque
lo que sabemos es que la tendencia del
clima del cual estamos viviendo hoy no
va no vamos a poder modificarla hasta el
año 2050 ya estamos en esa tendencia lo
que nos preocupa es lo que decía antes
es el problema de lo que estos eventos
climáticos extremos canícula que hay
ahora unas sequías que podría haber al
mismo tiempo esas cosas son más
difíciles de prevenir y hace falta que
trabajemos rápidamente en como nuestros
sistemas sean residentes puedan aceptar
una serie de esos situaciones extremas
para el futuro y ya para terminar de
forma breve qué parte de responsabilidad
tiene la agricultura de los últimos años
en el cambio climático la agricultura de
manera general cuenta por un cuarto de
las emisiones pero que se reparten de
manera diferente en el mundo en francia
es sobre todo para todo lo que va a ser
la mecanización todo el trabajo de campo
también los animales las vacas la
fermentación entérica
todo lo que va a ser la fertilización
otros países como brasil va a ser de
otros problemas como puede ser la
deforestación eso genera pues cada país
necesita definir sus estrategias
muy bien iñaki garcía de cortázar pues
muchísimas gracias por esta entrevista
por venir hasta nuestros estudios muchas
gracias a vosotros y muchísimas gracias
a todos ustedes por habernos acompañado
ya saben que nos pueden seguir en
internet en rdc y mundo.com y en
france24 punto com hasta pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]